can we talk about Woody Harrelson
speaking truth what do you say he was on
SNL bro what do you do he said that uh
maybe we should play it right here this
is just one little part of it stay
locked in their homes and people can
only come out if they take the cartels
drugs being forced to do drugs I do that
voluntarily all day long
why that delivery I mean that was that
might have been a good setup a good
premise but that delivery was horrible
well there's yeah there's no joke white
men can't tell jokes
how do you feel about that bro he was in
white man Kansas he would have delivered
that way better than that real joke
there
I think it was supposed to be but I
think he flubbed the teleprompter yeah
or maybe it wasn't written on the
teleprompter and he was like I'm done
getting these boosters by the way Jon
Stewart did that way better on Colbert
that was John John
Stewart did that one better Uncle Bill
not really it is different
was telling us that it was that [__]
came from the lab in Wuhan he's saying
it's uh the drug like the drug companies
or cartels that Pfizer and modern or
like whoever oh so he's joking more
about the vaccines
so it's about the origin of the virus
that's bull to do on SNL with that
liberal yeah audience yeah yeah didn't
like it I didn't it didn't hit I thought
a punchline was coming so it didn't hit
for me
it's just wild he did it yeah the
implication was a joke I didn't pick up
on that I just assumed the way he built
tension something's coming maybe that's
why I didn't hit because maybe it wasn't
in the prompter yeah because they knew
that if it was in the prompter it would
have been something they would have made
them change so maybe it wasn't something
he even rehearsed yeah and so he thought
he could go up there and wing it and
that [__] didn't goddamn flat yeah
because they have a dress rehearsal
before that's really the whole show and
that's right didn't do that in the dress
rehearsal and then that's right yeah
that's right
yeah what was the point of playing that
clip
um I feel like you had a point before
y'all because it just
saying
bring it up as like a genius piece of
comment yeah but I thought it was kind
of interesting to see like a mainstream
television show like SNL that always
like toes the company line yeah to at
least put out an attempt at a joke about
the pharmaceutical companies kind of
forcing people to get vaccinated yeah I
think folks know The Jig Is up yeah you
know what I mean it doesn't matter what
size you're on I think anybody with some
common sense and my eyes can look and be
like yeah all right that wasn't that
might have been bro do you see how they
slow rolled it like it was a couple
weeks ago they're like it turns out if
you have had covid that immunity is just
as good as the vaccine or the Boost yeah
right that was part one yeah and then
part two was uh yeah this [__] came from
China bro bro 90 of everything the
YouTube scientists were saying is right
has been true yo straight up um
[Music]
that's what they were doing when they
were Computing vaccine
but do you think people learn though
like do you think people get jaded from
this like let's say something similar
happens in five years do you think
people are like well remember when we
got lied to and they weren't telling us
the whole truth you're so irrational the
fear of death I think will most people
will still fall in line yeah I don't
know because I don't think people care
about fear anymore because once again we
had this conversation two weeks ago
there was three unidentified flying
objects flying over America yeah got
shot down they haven't retrieved no
wreckage they told us they don't know it
they don't think it's from China they
don't know where it's from and nobody
gave a [__] um you know what I mean like
the possibility of nuclear war I'm not
saying it's high but it's higher than
it's probably ever been in our lifetime
and nobody gives a [__] yeah you know
what I mean like